[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
right
um
me
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
or
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
good
thank you guys so much for coming out my
name is helen's channel we're gonna
watch people show that's not picture
which might
i just need someone
um i'm dating experts i'll kiss over
i'm constantly visiting something
um it's not a fun time i was just a
little faster you said everything given
all the action
uh so how this show works is uh no two
names in the bucket no lgbtqs today
sorry we're
uh
unfortunately bigger than uh close and i
did you know um but two days ago
and uh you go on a date for one minute
and then when the time's up you guys
sit there and then we interview you and
talk to you and find out more about
why you thought that would get you laid
and stuff like that and who you are as a
person and maybe
your hopes and dreams but uh should be a
good date are you guys ready for this
show
yeah
some of you are going to be on this
stage going on dates should be fun uh we
always have a guest on this show because
uh we don't want to overwhelm the dates
with my autistic energy we got a very
talented comedian tonight very funny
woman she's been on kill tony she's very
funny give it up for cat swatner
cat swatner in the house
what's up
good uh not much how about you
i'm good whoa
look at us a couple of comedians doing
well
how's your dating life going
it's actually going good for once wow
give it up for cat
he's a master sifu at dating
i am asian i have a boyfriend it's
pretty
exciting i have a girlfriend confusing
perplexing oh nice weird yeah
um you know we're gonna watch a lot of
people date each other it should be fun
we can impart upon them our wisdom
yeah are you good at dating
why would you ask that
no i love dating it's a fun back and
forth it's a great uh get great way to
get to know people uh are you guys ready
to get to know someone tonight
hopefully you're not going on a date
uh this first man coming up
with testosterone and yeah
and uh strength is grant
brenda the show grant
coming up look at him he's getting ready
to play disco
olivia
coming on up here her friends are giving
her support you can take the stairs oh
she's athletic
and a minute of shading from grant and
olivia starting now all right gotta get
serious for the state the hat is
backwards i'm gonna catch me a rare
pokemon right here
okay
are you from austin originally
dallas close
how about yourself um i'm from
california california okay
red flag uh we're from
bay area actually you know i don't
really know enough about the area to say
who you are based on
okay thank you
so
what brought you here overall
okay so like one night stand is that
what you're looking for sure why not
perfect
okay
mental note taken on that one
i did see you jump on to the stage so i
i believe you
do you do you do any gymnastics or how
did you get so flexible
alcohol made you more flexible
so just drinking it or like what happens
when you drink
do what jump on the street
okay
and time
[Applause]
give it up for olivia and grant
the super drunk olivia
that's a good sign that's not a red flag
at all that you're drunk on this date
i think i'm gonna need my drink on stage
david if i could get some assistance
he's ordering a waiter around
so olivia uh
how did you find your skill of being
able to uh jump on stage when you're
drunk have you done anything crazy while
you were drunk before
i gave myself a concussion once
usually peop other people do that for
you but
do that
i fell off my bike
you were okay so you're drunk biking
you're from california
so you were drunk biking
a lot of red flags i think i've made
that clear
this is not a good first date this isn't
good first big material i gotta say
yeah taking a big risk being vulnerable
yeah this show could also be called the
red flag olympics but
i i think you might win gold for this
one but we're only just barely into the
date maybe we should you guys both did
agree to go on a date on stage so that's
the first red flag
so grant uh how's your dating life been
it's been really fun uh ever since i
moved here and
separated from my girlfriend it's it's
been a one paddle board date to uh
eeyore's
birthday celebration this weekend have
you heard of that before you look like
eeyore
i'm not nearly used to the energy of a
happy eeyore
it's very impressive what'd you do at
eora's birthday um the only thing you
can do uh you do a lot of um illegal
things and look a lot at other people
doing illegal things sounds like a red
flag what was this
wasn't that peace park it was where we
play basketball sometimes nice ketamine
am i what are you doing ketamine what
kind of drugs are you doing um
no since it's on the internet i'll just
say it's the ones that uh enhance uh
festivals and grow naturally on the
ground is your boss here or something is
it no uh well he was actually at the
event he invited me to be a volunteer so
i was working security i was i was on
the job a security guard on mushrooms
that's
that's what i look for in a security
guard is uh
altered consciousness just empathize
really well with people on drugs but hey
man i'm sorry you cannot live this way
olivia have you ever done drugs before
oh what kind of drugs illegal kinds
yes
yes i've i've done illicit substances
holy [ __ ] you guys have so much in
common yes
what do you like you like blow or
um blow i like all all of it
all of it
which is your favorite to go biking on
cocaine
she's entering the tour de france
gonna be in the men's division
uh olivia how long have you been in uh
austin
about 24 hours so you're going back to
san francisco soon say yes
well you know you're you're probably
gonna you probably miss the homeless
people in san francisco so you need to
get back you're sick of the austin
homeless i'm really
um
honestly you know i just love all the
tech bros who have gentrified everything
and pushed housing prices skyrocketed
that doesn't happen in austin at all i
don't know what you're talking about
yes
what tech are you anna grant
i'm in cyber security cyber security and
what drugs do you use to do cyber
security
uh
what was the one you were talking about
earlier he does meth ladies and
gentlemen he doesn't want to tell you
you're on a date with the method have
you ever been on a date with a crazy guy
that you didn't realize was crazy until
it's too late
those are most dates i go on
have you tried dating or trash
grants
what's that what's the craziest date
you've been on ooh
um
man i i do have a good answer this one
let me think um
okay i so i was invited to be a wingman
for a friend of mine he's older he's a
down and out la actor he just said hey
uh
my friend's got a really cute blonde
friend that we want to go back to her
place and party with and i was just like
okay
sure i'm new to austin down to meet some
new people some other people
and uh
they picked us up in her mercedes she
was driving
she was this what's the crazy part
we go back to her place
do some illicit drugs and then the next
day we're at the pool doing cyber
security yes cyber security things
and
she
flips a [ __ ] on my friend for having a
glass like an amber herd
absolutely
she
flipped a [ __ ] on him she basically like
started harassing him to leave the pool
at his own pool
and i had to like bounce her out of the
pool
yeah until we're fighting and she's like
you do security on your off time yeah
hire me please uh
so she then directs her anger at me
she's like your friends suck your
apartments suck and you suck you chose
them over me i'm like yeah i just met
you last night like
very much in amber heard uh do bros
before hoes yeah absolutely
what david what do you think kat what do
you think about that long story short
crazy dates yeah okay let's hear from
cat first
i mean i just it's
i don't know it was just kind of um you
got nothing crazier than that
i'll save that for later maybe he is a
tech bro that's as crazy as he gets
one time this girl wouldn't even get on
my bird scooter it's so lame
olivia what's the craziest thing that
has happened to you on a date um i think
the weirdest one was this guy who was
like oh why don't we
draw each other with our non-dominant
hands and i thought he was joking he
wasn't
so um he like mid-date pulls out
clipboards and was like oh i
i brought paper pens and clipboards for
us to draw each other with our
non-dominant hands
and i was like all right so we did
what it's me
on an app
okay which one
oh god i don't remember scribbler
i don't know it's been a long time but
yeah that was probably the that might
that's one of the weirder ones but he
doesn't know where you live that's good
mine knows where i live i'm very worried
no he also gonna shoot you with her
non-dominant hand
go to this cafe and then sit down and
not order anything it's like
wow that's not that guy sounds frugal i
want to go on a date with him
facebook like and this one i lived in
the south like in the tech area of the
bay area and he was like he did like
data work for basically you're telling
me facebook is an unethical company
and the people that work there are
douchebags yeah but no he definitely
made a lot of money and was still
yeah still drawing with his non-dominant
hand
he could have hired someone to draw you
it was a very bad job it does not look
like me at all i still have the picture
why do you have it do you look at it
sometimes and think man that guy was
stupid
he told me he was like
i had a dream that i was in grad school
for art history and i was like oh do you
like art he was like yeah i was like
okay so like what kind of art he's like
all art
that's a good good answer did you put it
on your fridge like a little kids it's
on
my parents house in my bedroom
when you get murdered they're going to
show that in the documentary
it's probably this guy
that's that's disturbing
have you ever been on any crazy dates
cat
uh
yeah i went on a date with this guy one
time who brought his brother
and his brother was the only one that
talked
and he sat on his hands all the time and
like rocked back and forth like he had
something going on yeah that was this
caseworker
yeah and then he messaged me afterwards
like hey
had a great time let's hang out again i
was like dude yeah me and my brother are
going to a concert we should come with
he's like i hope you don't mind i
brought my brother to this date
from tinder next date family reunion
it was uh yeah i took a break after that
is that how they have sex probably like
he's just watching and his brother's
doing all the work and asks you for
review after i mean those are some vibes
i could pick up on the brother cute at
least like i don't remember no he's old
oh he's real old i mean not old
75 no i don't know he's in 40.
i did date a 40 year old man though once
when i was 19. but anyway um
whoa what was his name and uh where does
he live we're going to send the cops
there right now
his name was harry
which is a very old man named harold
and he moved back in with his parents
recently
you still keep in touch with him i mean
yeah you know why yeah aging is a red
flag but you know
living with your parents too he was a i
liked him because he was an alcoholic so
like your dad or
my dad's not a nail collar he's my mom
oh yeah where would you take olivia on a
date
okay um since you're flexible
uh maybe we could
go to
a
hippie festival together and do some
gymnastics in the park
on drugs
grant would you be good at gymnastics or
are you more of a basketball kind of guy
i'm neither but uh i would i would
attempt to do it
and uh if i was high enough we could try
some flips or something
as long as we're high enough
what what do you like to do with your
free time
i go to a lot of comedy shows
i
go outside a lot paddle board
take the dog out all the basic white guy
things you know okay it's pretty boring
okay pretty golden retriever-ish olivia
what's fun to do where do you go on
dates in san francisco the tenderloin
um i actually don't live in san
francisco i live in fresno
oh yeah applying to us
totally different things the the fresno
crowd is
fresno more like fresh hose am i right
you've clearly never been to fresno
there's nothing there
yeah fresno way am i going there
um but uh where do you where do you go
on dates in fresno
there are a couple bars
that i like maybe you guys could do yoga
together you just seem very flexible
that would have probably been a easier
transition than the high gymnastics
glad you're here to tell us
bad decisions is a hobby clearly
how what happened when you were biking
drunk where was this
and why did you fall
young i was in my early 20s
so five years ago
or two years ago i should have said
yeah
um it was when i lived in new orleans
and i was very [ __ ] up and i got on my
bike to go home after a night out
you were listening to some jazz on
bourbon street
no one goes to bourbon street it sucks
and you fell on a cobblestone street or
were you wearing a helmet
your helmet
no condoms got it
no protection period
and
so
new orleans was built on a swamp so
there's a lot of subsidence with the
streets
which means a lot of potholes
and you fell into one
think so
did you like fly off i could not tell
you
and what were the symptoms of the
concussion i had the worst headache i've
ever had in my life was it a hangover or
was it i thought it was a hangover but
then i had a headache for 10 straight
days
you think it affects you now
i mean you think you're okay you think
you're impulsive
maybe climbing up on things that you
shouldn't i wasn't working with a lot to
start so
trying to finish the job
it's like why i had two brain cells left
was just trying to kill them
well you seem very smart you live in
fresno uh what do you do for a living
um i work for an environmental justice
community based org
state policy wow she's vaccinated
and boosted for sure
grant are you vaccinated absolutely are
you boosted no didn't think so
you are hereby revoked from paddleboard
privileges
damn it biden disapproves of you um
that's cool uh you guys uh have anything
you want to say to each other sort of
romantically into each other's eyes
i think you should get boosted
i think i could give you
he's tall enough he doesn't need a
booster
i think i could give you a grade two
concussion tonight
yikes i mean i am susceptible to them
because once you've had one you're more
likely to get a second one
give it up for domestic violence
i think that was a passive
confession
grant and olivia she's climbing
she's jumping down very athletic
grant could probably climb down easier
there's only two women signed up the
more women the better or else dudes have
to go on dates with each other
which
is fun
and it's fun to see two dudes talk to
each other
we got chase price
coming up here
and suzanne
who's suzanne so then from table from
olivia's table
coming up
suzanne and chase price
the bucket
there's only one more woman left
we're gonna have to conserve this woman
and use her wisely
if you're a woman i encourage you to
sign up dudes
i encourage you to take your name out of
the bucket no i'm kidding
we love all genders here chase price
going once going twice
too bad
have fun
i
i think it's us that god put that up
khan
from the legend of khan
a star trek fan
give it up for khan and suzanne
everyone clap for
pawn and suzanne
and go
talk to each other like you want to [ __ ]
each other
oh you have beautiful thank you
thank you didn't you get
anything interesting your abercrombie
shirt thank you yeah it says fitch on it
that's how i figured it's abercrombie
isn't that bad like for shaming fat
people or something happen with this
brand
oh like they shame fat people yeah they
did they did do that so am i cancelled
for wearing this yes oh [ __ ] i think you
should probably let's replace it just
kidding that was mean you didn't have
spare shirts i can borrow yeah
this is y'all it's time oh okay
so
uh
i like your watch uh apple watch that's
pretty extraordinary yes i have never
seen one before they are very rare i
have to run a marathon so i have to be
able to track how much i can actually
run oh and how many slave labor did you
needed to make one uh
i don't know actually probably not as
many as
i don't know how to answer that question
and time
give it up for suzanne and khan
bringing up slavery on the first date
that's a bold move
no well how does that usually go
so sorry how does bringing up slavery
what what was the best case scenario for
that i know make them feel bad about
themselves
his self-esteem
continuing to do that yeah
so you have an apple watch and you're
running a marathon holy [ __ ] that's
that's a lot which one the austin
marathon
oh sorry from uh
okay
apparently it's pretty easy for people
who don't run marathons
yeah why are you running a marathon uh
new year's resolution and forced myself
to raise money for charity
congratulations yes thank you what a
good person
what are you what are you doing khan you
raising any money for charity or just
shaming people on dates you go on oh no
i wish i could be as philanthropic as
her i'm just being a nuisance to society
i've been to the festival yesterday what
festival
everyone's birthday what my friend was
telling it's
your first birthday
like saying happy birthday to everyone
and i asked him why he said like he
thought it was everyone's birthday so i
thought like that was the funniest part
that was pretty fun yeah foreigners say
the damnedest things
i can say that i'm half foreign
um that's cool you know you're
supporting abercrombie and fitch while
uh suzanne's supporting her charity
um
what uh what brings you to austin you
live here now oh no i actually moved
here from washington dc like six months
back so whoa you're a political
political bro
no i
like to remain neutral just make fun of
liberals and conservatives as an
outsider so okay you like to rip the rib
rolls
um what uh what brings you to austin
i know just was tired of snow shoveling
snow all day and night and just wanted
to get out of the east coast i feel like
austin people are much more friendlier
than east coast people that is true we
are very much friendlier than those east
coast [ __ ]
and less snow unless you like humidity
i work from indoor so i feel bad for
people working outside but it doesn't
affect yeah we all do they're called the
homeless people
we look down on them
uh suzanne where are you from
hughes
went to school in north carolina and
then moved back here
wow all in the south
what's your favorite part of the south
uh
the lack of
cold
cold okay you guys have that in common
maybe you guys could go on a vacation in
the caribbean that's exactly my plan
that's wonderful do you guys have any
more
weather comments
for
i got to be honest i feel like watching
that was do you remember in anchorman
when like is it
kristen wiig and steve carolla going on
that date that's what that reminded me
of anyway uh very awkward
the dancing
yes
you would be the woman in that example
you're steve carell no
you have a bright movie career ahead of
you
bless um i mean
i feel like if these two were to get
into marriage uh suzanne married yeah to
be in a relationship i think uh suzanne
would be really nice and
i think khan would get drunk every night
and be a piece of [ __ ] i'm a very nice
person
even
do you like to present yourself
as a piece of [ __ ] on every date
no i'm the best guy like you can ask my
friends
that supports that point now yeah it's
the best guy
what uh what's the best thing that
you've done like the kindest thing that
you've done
um
helped my friend realize yesterday that
it wasn't everyone's birthday was uh
winnie the pooh's
the dog yours it's yours birthday
you corrected him incorrectly
you know just told him about the
backstory about the winnie the pooh
about how the donkey was sad and i would
love to hear the backstory of winnie the
pooh from you
i feel like you have a very interesting
take on winnie the pooh
yeah yep i used to post a lot of stuff
about winnie the pooh and compare him
with a chinese president so yep
oh he's a redditor
what
what uh what what do you think about
winnie the pooh what's your general take
on winnie the pooh right now it's the
same as south park i like him south park
i've never heard winnie the pooh
compared to south park
you're watching the episode it's really
nice they're like can you do a winnie
the pooh impression
no
he's just too nice you know just like oh
bother
yeah i guess i have to like get more
concussions where are you from khan i'm
from well it's gonna i'm from eastern
europe specifically russia so whoa where
i don't know that
eastern europe had a mexico in it why
are you so tan yeah
i just
ever since i came to austin i've been
tanned so a tan russian wow
where do you miss it
do you miss it
uh sometimes yes like you like borscht
and [ __ ]
sorry what
borscht
you like that's all i know about russia
i feel like no i just don't like the
cold but i kind of like the
straightforward answers that my people
give you know we don't like shoe
recording stuff do you want to invade
ukraine yes
straightforward
yeah just straight to the point
it's wonderful
um
sorry oh no it's fine did you did you
date a lot of russian women uh no
actually not that much it's like i am in
the united states why rush day russian
woman when i can have other
people like meet other people
you're sick of russians you want you
want variety
yup exactly just like austin thing right
you guys try out different food like go
to different food drugs yeah i try not
to compare humans to food
dan have you ever dated a russian before
no
it doesn't seem like you're rushing to
do it right now
i can't tell if he's trying to
i don't know i look not russian i think
trying to what
there was food involved there oh eat you
he's trying to wipe you up
he wants to take you back to russia
i don't think she will like it it's very
cold do you like cold no i went to
russia once and it was very cold and
very gray and
it's kind of like you know like when you
see those like tv shows in which they
put up the yellow filter whenever
they're showing latin america
uh mexico that's right yeah
that's exactly russia like they put up
the grave filter over there so
wait why did you go to russia
sorry
like basic white girl [ __ ] went on a
cruise with like my family i'm cruised
to russia
who takes a cruise to russia
my mom got bored of russia
does not do well in the sunshine we went
to places that have cloud cover and
history
yeah history of death and famine
i think like literally germany and like
we went to holocaust
like oh my god you guys know how to
party
you guys are [ __ ] doing ecstasy going
to holocaust museums
murray family party's hard
that's your last name yeah
uh
khan what kind of uh
name is that is that russian or
no that's because uh i'm a mx so my dad
is russian my mom is from asia so i kind
of took out two names so
yeah but i like the name since
especially since i used to do boxing so
it kind of went well with my boxing yeah
yeah yeah and you were saying that you
didn't get concussions i think you're
more concussed than uh olivia
oh i'm definitely sure about that i'm
just trying to like hit the rock bottom
and you know like the phoenix rises from
the ashes that's my
beautiful yeah so you're a boxer did you
watch the boxing match yesterday
um it wasn't canelo right now
yeah
i have
got too much ct so i can't even remember
anymore so
what a convenient excuse
do you feel safe that he knows boxing he
could protect you if you ever go to
russia olivia's my friend so she'll
protect me what's olivia going to do do
the splits
yeah no she's
rapping
just make sure she's not sober
get her drunk if you want her to protect
you and she'll
kick him in the face heck yeah
suzanne uh what's your dating life like
um
[Music]
not great
oh oh
that's pretty much the end of that what
uh what makes this so not great um
i've heard that austin people describe
austin as being full of like peter pans
like men who never want to grow up
mm-hmm and i think that's kind of um the
problem like russian 40 year olds that
were abercrombie and fitch
that's a good line i was not directing
it with him
so you're like a man who's mature and
grown yeah
well that's what dallas is for right
dallas buyers club
austin is weird
i yeah dating here does suck it's pretty
terrible yeah do you have like a
community of any kind no no i my
co-workers are all in their like late
50s and they all have families and it's
like super fun but mm-hmm
super fun i mean our idea of fun is
suspect you went to russia on a cruise
and i tell them about like
not having kids
you want kids
[Music]
whoa
what was that i don't know i don't know
if she wants them or not
so today because
we were talking about the climate crisis
and how that
problem our children's ability to live
you don't want them farting making it
worse
yeah that's that is exactly literally
verbatim is what olivia said
olivia she's very flexible and
intellectually
um
do you want kids
uh no i have seen a lot of kids and i i
realize i don't like them that much yeah
[ __ ] kids
where have you seen a lot of kids
i don't know at the walmart you know
when they're throwing [ __ ] away and you
want to smack them but you can't do it
well you can in russia
well then you have to find their dad and
the russians don't
[ __ ] around when it comes to protecting
their kids so you know oh you don't have
kids in russia
now you don't want to fight with their
parents because they will go medieval on
you so
what do you mean find their dads
you know like they walk around with
their dads
oh yeah
okay like all kids walk around with
their dads at least most of
them i've seen their moms are staying at
home since so cold so i guess
i would not be a good russian mom
you could stay inside
um so you're you see a lot of kids with
dads in russia that's cool
yeah good that they stick around
so interesting learning about other
cultures
i'm gonna drink some vodka and watch my
child
what asian are you
um my mom is from pakistan so
oh so like middle eastern
it's very far southeast asia okay
did you tell me more about asia
no uh pakistan's pretty cool that's
that's where the tannis comes in you
know i uh i i thought that you were
mexican or
hispanic but uh yeah any anything you
get from the pakistani side of your
family do you uh celebrate ramadan or
yeah i do um i can speak like five
languages even though i've lost a lot of
iq cells due to blessings so i'm
forgetting most of the languages but
yeah i'm really into southeast asian
food asian food so what languages
pastor persian english
and urdu and hindi so
wow half of those are
and uh which language do you like to
blame people for slavery in
oh definitely english i went to
that way they can understand it and also
shame them you know you guys used to be
bad people but now you are gentrifying
austin and making difficult for everyone
else yeah we use moved here
i know
i still can't afford it
and she's from texas
we should build a wall
to keep out all these russian pakistanis
should we start
chanting we should uh
wasn't your previous president
very supportive russia from what i
remembered i feel like we should leave
i think you're talking about donald j
trump and uh yes he was very supportive
of everything awesome including putin
okay
i won't have you talk [ __ ] about our
glorious leader
when your glorious leader is invading a
country and starting world war three
right now
khan
he's just having fun you know just
popping okay he's just having fun
you and uh suzanne have very similar
ideas of fun you know
certainly very similar
give it up for suzanne and khan they
went on a date
i think they're gonna
exchange phone numbers maybe
we're down to our last woman
so if there's a woman that wants to sign
up we'd love for you to sign up laurel
you're the only woman i know in here
with us cat
yeah this is we're about to enter the
gay part of the show we got
pedro valenzuela coming up
he just like
going on a date with
artie
artie the woman
here comes artie
going on a date with pedro valenzuela
pedro valenzuela
this came from an uber eats delivery
going on a date with artie oh he's
pulling out the chair very slightly
almost did nothing to help but here they
go on a date pedro and artie
what's up it's how's it going already
in art
so actually
it's pronounced starting strong what
arty arty yes okay so are you uh
middle easter no
no good okay
so i was kind of hoping it wasn't what
where are you well where are you from uh
i was born and raised in chicago um okay
and uh we're playing that game yeah and
i'm going to tell my ethnicity but
indian
um okay
yeah nice yeah what about you uh i'm
dominican
um
kind of uh lost my breath up here i came
up here with a lot of confidence
it's starting to wane
really uh yeah well then we're good
what you drinking on what's that
a double
an elbow it's a double oh a double okay
i was like i don't know what an elbow is
but you've got a long star yeah
yeah you know
because i'm
lonely what what did you do today uh
i got up
i had a uber eats coupon
yeah i use that hey 25
off which is pretty good uh golden chick
it's pretty good uh end time
give it up for the uber eats connoisseur
pedro valenzuela
with the chicago mobster art artie
artie
that's where it's at hey
look it's khan's mother except she looks
younger than her son
um
artie uh what did you think about uh
pedro's exciting exciting day today he
woke up and he ate food
i mean that sounds about right
i would love to start my day that way i
usually do a second date yeah
let's okay she's uncomfortable
no no sorry but
food sounds good i'm making it weird
brunch
okay
that was honestly horrific
what did you think about that date
me honestly
it was horrific you can't that's
terrific pedro you took a lot of deep
breaths tonight are you working on your
yoked up those steps and there was a lot
of steps like four or five steps and uh
i'm out of breath
i'm out of shape i'm out of breath i
think it was the golden chick probably
uh
i think i'm gonna do a three-year-old
joint
uh no i don't smoke weed anymore a lot
of paranoia issues uh
try not to bring that up on a date
just say that you're taking sober
october in april okay
oh [ __ ] hugged
as a child as your mama
i got a lot of hugs that might have been
the problem maybe too many hugs yeah
it looks like you've never given someone
a hug in your life that was super
awkward
well i mean
look already i want to hear about you
okay
hey pedro um what is going on whoa
why is everyone so weird with me you
know what days like when you're yelling
at the audience i'm on this stage 10
times a week
where where do you what did you do today
did you wake up and eat
uh yeah let's see what happened yeah we
did we woke up we ate and um where do we
go
we you went with multiple who said
somewhere
who said what pedro i stopped talking to
the audience we're talking about she eat
already
talking about it have another coupon i
can give you the coupon if you need
don't listen to these people this is
what happens when comedians sign up for
this show sometimes they try to take it
over
i'm not dude hey
stop talking where's talking we're
hearing about artie's day right now
already had a very exciting day she went
with multiple people somewhere
to eat
cisco's
we recommend it
and then i thought it was a went for a
long walk it got really sweaty like
could see
pit stains and stuff like it was bad but
it's awesome for you well luckily you're
wearing a sleeveless thing right now so
true but did you
so it comes through and that's the real
deal
we all sweat
uh in the south they say the women
glisten
is that does that help
are you here help the situation what do
you mean yeah
yeah it's not saying [ __ ]
guys it's gonna be fine okay i'm weird
you don't have to be weird it's okay
pedro when's the last time you went on a
date
what
when's the last time you went on a date
somebody wanted to go out on real date
tonight
oh i'm turning on arty you got up what
you got options what date are you going
on tonight you people don't like me stop
talking to the audience [ __ ] laughing
look at me stop looking at the audience
what uh what what date are you going on
tonight
me yeah no i'm not what's the last date
you've been on
uh it was probably a pre-pandemic uh
now you laugh so yeah when i make fun of
yelling at the audience
how did it go free pandemic uh it was
with my girlfriend at the time so broke
up
we broke up right before the pandemic
and mostly her uh then
i uh
did you eat
no it was it was like a farewell
a
farewell hey
yeah she wanted me to move to florida
and i was like i'm not going to florida
but in hindsight i went to la which was
completely shut down and i probably
should have went to florida because
i probably would have been better at
comedy
is pre-pandemic
uh yeah pretty pandemic so this is like
one and a half years ago what's up artie
well you first date in like three years
no i was i did a date on here does that
count how'd it go
uh it went substantially better than
this one i brought pizza though i feel
like that probably helped
they're all about food oh yeah i love
food that's why i got mad when someone
was like oh like it's like don't turn on
food
that's his handiwork what do you do for
a living you uber eating
uh no i deliver for agb
hgb oh sorry i didn't mean to assume
yeah
way better
frozen pizza heb brand i will agree on
that do you have an oven
yes okay
that's going to be about
i don't have an oven
frozen pizza brand yeah he's good have
you tried it no i don't have an oven so
oh i wouldn't feel like i
he's jealous of you
it's got oven envy the salsa at h-e-b
it's like hgb brand salsa i've had uh
the spinach
what the spinach is pretty good
lheb uh the produce
yeah yeah the produce uh i wish they
sold a single serving
because i have to get a bag of spinach
and then i don't want to finish the
whole bag
so then i'm forced to eat more spinach
than i want is this the turkey science
however in america
okay artie's traumatized
take another day dude no i will not get
off the [ __ ] stage
laurel you want to go on a date
please save us
we got a
person that's not pedro coming up
robert lagoon
robert lagoon are you in the building
robert
going once going twice
no for robert lagoon
uh we got thong dwong
here he comes stuang an asian man
thank god
laurel
going on a date for the third time in
the show's history with dwong
probably like the fifth fifth time wow
that's my first time so welcome
what are you thinking so far what's your
judgment
not used to this
do you go to comedy a lot
um i haven't went to comedy in them in a
bit but um like all the other guys i
went to the festival yesterday me too oh
do you
what do you went on
shrooms oh that seems like the crowd
favorite yeah okay cool here same here
we probably bump into each other without
knowing it
oh
like a big hippie like a white shirt and
just like i'm
not just meditating somewhere in the
park
okay i was wearing a red sparkles
i think i might have saw you
maybe
so um i guess tell me about yourself
that was the first day i ever went on
here and that's the question too so
what's the answer
um
tell me about myself
just
what do you want to know
um
what do you do for a living i'm in the
energy industry like media and
events
oh
it's time already
time
code up for laurel it was that bad
she's in the energy industry
unfortunately there's no energy to be
found on this date
duang uh you said that you were dressed
like a hippie and then all you said you
was you were wearing a white shirt
yes
what kind of hippies are you hanging out
with uh just wear white shirts
uh
i don't know i'm trying to make my own
little hippie thing going on okay like a
cult yes
so you're just wearing a white shirt to
an event where people dress up
yep
and you're you're dressed pretty snazzy
today you got the uh suspenders
yeah
trying a bit
what uh doing my best what you want
you're going for that uh redneck asian
look
yes very austin like kind of mix
texas hippie
hipster
hipster so you're a tech pro
yes
semiconductor
oh
chip
funny
used to
i
went down the street to applied material
so not that much better
i think he's still
okay
thanks for calling me out laurel
yeah semiconductor that fits because
this day was
semi-conducive to
love making
dong what kind of asian are you
vietnamese damn
he'll kill you you're not careful he's
good at warfare
what do you think about this date cat
um i feel like yeah
nothing was really sad
you know
uh i feel like thong you're you're you
were
sort of stalling for time you're like
vibing out
too much what do you like to do for fun
drugs
drugs
yeah are you on any right now or is this
just you sober as a kite i gotta be
sober from yesterday i'm gonna ease out
a bit
so this is you
completely clear-headed yep
what do you like when you're on drugs
then
much happier calmer
yeah calm down thong jesus
jumping out of your seat right now
uh what what uh where did you grow up
dallas
well
austin awesome oh you're so you're local
kind of yeah so
nice you guys are both from austin
that's cool both been to east high
school
what which high school i went to a
charter school
yeah she's white dong she didn't go to
the school that we went to
what the
where did you go
what neighborhood like did you go
sugarville high okay so
nobody
oh [ __ ] that's the ghetto high school
i don't know any i'm not from here i was
just making [ __ ] up
um so
laurel what uh what's the last date
you've been on
oh that wasn't good
the date or the question
the date
what happened did someone fall off their
bike in front of you
[Music]
whoa
that sounds
further worse and i've never been in a
situation like that before man
sounds like a crime i'm glad we asked
we should really get the cops involved
in this show sometimes i think we need
some security here for sure
cruz they're good true really
do you have any like funny date memories
like something awkward that happened or
oh that's fun
not off the top of my head no okay
do you tell me
um
i mean i remember one time i was making
out with this guy and his lips were like
this like they're like really hard
and i was like why don't you like loosen
up your lips a little bit he's like
really on the first date you're gonna
critique my kissing
and then we had sex anyway but i never
saw him again you know was it hard to
put it in his butthole because he was
puckering his butthole so hard no sorry
i like bloodstuffs hurts um
i like how uh
you just shamed a white man for having
no lips maybe that's just because you
know what white people don't have lips
so we had them he was just like
doing that for something you guys
playing like a trumpet yeah
so that's that's good advice that we
should all
take note on
yeah loosen your lips for the kiss
it'll make your mouth look like an
[ __ ]
what's the uh
what's what's the last time you kissed
someone when's the last time you kissed
someone how did it go what were your
lips doing
um
not tight he's got loose lips ladies
do people tell you you're a good kisser
no no no no
no what is the one thing that you get
the most compliments on sexually
uh
my ass your ass can we all see thongs at
can you do a squat for us real quick
do a little spin oh i have to yeah
sorry
the long's ass ladies and gentlemen whoa
look at that he can hike up and down the
ho chi minh trail with that thing
yes i can
you work out or
yeah i do mma with khan over there oh
[ __ ] i take back everything i said
you are very sexy and you don't seem
like you're high on drugs right now at
all
what's your favorite move in the mma
like my favorite combo yeah so
jab
overhead
overhand cross and then you pinch the
nipple
and a hulk
yes jesus christ this combination is
very long
well just full combo jab overhand hook
i mean overhead hook and kick
can you show us that combo with your
glorious ass
objectifying himself for us give it up
for thong in his mma career
whoa
there you go
that's great you sort of half punched
everything
it's all about the footwork
it's all about the booty work with you
that
badass
uh so that's kind of cool isn't that
cool he knows mixed martial arts he
could probably i'd like to learn
yeah
what would you like to learn what's the
move that you you're looking to get into
as if you're walking away but you swing
your leg back around and they don't even
know it's coming oh yeah
oh [ __ ]
sounds like a move that would work on a
dude that pinched your nipple
like i'm gonna go wait a minute i'm
right here kicking you in the face
that's a badass could you
no i wish i cannot
i think that's a wheel kick
that sounds awesome
yeah just surprise [ __ ]
yeah but i've been hanging out with joe
rogan i don't know if you know him uh
ufc commentator just flying on his
private jet and uh you're his pj getting
yelled at
do you always have a lollipop
it's so whimsical
by a smoke shop
also has weed in it i'm pure
what a little bit oh french but you like
big brunch oh yeah she went to a charter
school
this is just easy for her hey thong
do you know any french from your days in
vietnam no i don't bug it
you know
yeah me
fusion
yeah
yeah okay
i got nothing what's your signature move
on a date
that the flexing
it's awesome the tattoo i guess she
spills a drink do you take your shirt
off
you do the combo thing you did earlier
that's what i start with
yeah
so uh have you been any fights
no
not that good of a fighter get like
performance anxiety and i just get
punched in the face quite a bit so
when was the last time you got punched
in the face
a week ago a week ago what happened
we always get punched in the face
it looked like a
controlled punch in the face yes
planned
when was the last time you had an
unplanned punch in the face
uh
gulf of tonkin i don't really try to get
into fights okay if that's what you're
going for what's the point of knowing
mma if you never use it
it's like having a gun and never
shooting someone
that's the point of it
whoa he's a philosopher
well thong thank you for going on a date
laura would you want to go on another
date with the man
party
who's
already oh the woman
artie you want to go on a lesbian date
with laurel
where's artie artie
she's there with her boyfriend
she's coming up
she's married
[Applause]
give it up for thong
no kick your ass if you don't
party and laurel going on a
date on other people comedy show
give it up for artie
you know when you meet a friend for the
first time and you're like
they're so [ __ ] cool
i want to hang out with them so at first
it feels like a friend date because
you're like trying to impress each other
that's what this feels like
that's lovely i was watching you from my
seat over there and i was like you know
what i could be your friend like thank
you
how's that lollipop that's great it kind
of has an aftertaste
but the initial doesn't have to take it
would you do today
what did i do
you look more way more excited than the
the previous date you're saying thank
you
i was probably i probably looked really
spooked but yeah i went paddle boarding
yoga paddle boarding with my one of my
friends
would you and like an environmental do
you do any poses on the pedalboard yeah
which
which ones
probe sun
okay then
like one
foot back i don't know the names of
stuff are you a yoga teacher
i i uh did the training you did the
training and time
give it up for laurel and artie
laurel asking an indian person if she's
a yoga instructor
kind of a race
program too so
oh yes
uh the second best thing to an indian
woman teaching you is a white woman
teaching yoga
uh so uh yeah i mean you guys are both
friend zoned but you guys seem happy
about it you know
you guys want to touch titties or
something about that
no we can't uh
abuse women like we can thwang on this
show
i think enough titties have been touched
right
yeah from your previous date like some
[ __ ] went down i'm so bruised from it's
like oh my god
i'm so sorry
it's better than that one time when i
came up here after like my friend died
and my dog died in the same weekend oh
yeah i remember that
wait
no
she's been on the show multiple times
she's still single so that shows you how
well this show works
uh what do you keep coming back for
it's just so entertaining and obscure
and i love obscure things
thank you for saying it's poorly
attended
i love how nobody knows about this chef
my second time back
wow last sunday welcome thank you for
signing up
you saw it and you were like okay this
is relatively safe as long as
are you single
no i'm married happily married are you
guys looking for a third no oh all right
maybe in fourth
i'll watch i'll just videotape it
how did you meet your hus hubby
hubby and i met at the workplace at the
work place at the world place i broke my
biggest rule which was i'm not going to
date a co-worker but i was like oh
look at that chunk of vanilla gorilla
over there
is he your boss or just a co-worker use
co-worker okay
what where do you work
now currently oh when you met your uh
hubby uh we worked at this um
design build construction company
so he was like a manual labor and you
were the manager
well
no it was design build so i was on the
design side and he was on the build side
so kind of okay so it's like a art
architecture kind of thing
nice wait what did you guys make besides
beautiful romance
uh what
oh well i worked on warehouses which was
dry as hell and then
he did a multi-family so that was kind
of exciting i don't know
cool so you were building like confirm
yikes you want my resume
she works in energy
she laurel you work in energy have you
met anyone in your workspace that you
thought i could uh settle down with this
fella
oh and then what happened
and then he died and your dog died
usually i flirt and i try to sell but so
i don't want to create that reputation
so you don't want to date co-workers
yeah
that's really tricky how did how did
that go down how did you uh break that
rule like what happened
that's a good question
so this is what went down we were like
oh we're really enjoying what we're
doing
no sorry flip flip flip
we really like each other but we really
hate where we work oh my god you said
the opposite thing
that's why i said flip flip flip
but no what happened was that like we
were like this sucks we both hate our
job let's get back at them by [ __ ]
each other
it was like the love for each other was
building at the same time the love the
yeah all that was happening so we
schemed an exit plan we moved to seattle
did you guys like go on dates while you
were working there yeah who asked you
out huh who has two out
uh
he did
did he email you
uh we're just already
cell phones from the companies let's
circle back on this thing for
yourself so
i looked up his number on the directory
and i texted him and i was like hey
so you tested it first
wow that's hot what do you do
laurel
energy
you sell energy what
whenever i explain it people are like
what do you mean
but i work in the i work with utilities
across the nation to help
consult and create their decarbonization
plans
and then i
help clean tech companies connect with
the utilities who actually want to give
a [ __ ] so do you work for city of austin
utilities
yeah they're one of our partners man
can you lower my heating bill
you get a friends and family discount
we actually austin energy made the most
during the february freeze because they
were smart
and then they gave us like 70 dollars
back yeah as a flex parade on death row
yeah it was it was good um
nice
while the rest of the state is freezing
to death unvaccinated
you guys are just safely
warmed in your homes
not coughing on each other
um laurel so uh do would you know her a
construction company maybe you could
consult maybe you guys could work
together and maybe you know that's how
that's how her first romance happened
happens
i i would say we should email each other
i think this time on linkedin level
that's good
okay i think so
this is how you date in austin it's
called dating tech bros or texas
so uh what uh what was i gonna ask i was
gonna ask like uh have you ever dated
women before laurel no
but
you saw artie and you're like hubba
hubba
well compared to a lot of the other guys
i've had on the show i'd rather be with
the
yeah well it doesn't seem like she's
gonna snap and yell at the audience at a
moment's notice
shout out to pedro
uh artie have you ever dated a woman or
been bi-curious
no i haven't dated a woman but i have a
lot of girl friends and then they like
ghost me and it's really weird girls are
weird
yeah you're telling me
there's three of you up here i don't
know what to do
um but this is cool this is like your
first uh girl date
i guess
what uh what do you guys think you could
you'd do you know get in a subaru go uh
definitely go stand up paddleboarding
yeah yeah
like that's my plan actually next
weekend sorry i'm not gonna make to the
sunday show i'm gonna go stand up
teleport
instead
well you know seems a lot safer than uh
coming here and getting yelled at by
incels
um but uh where are you going paddle
boarding lake uh lady bird lake
i think so yeah nice and you're at yogi
right
yeah i'll start at the end and work my
way down
and then hopefully no bets are coming
out
know what that that they [ __ ] on you
so what's that position you were talking
about with one leg up behind you
you didn't know what it was called
it's like i don't know
we
i can see why you failed your i can see
why you failed your yoga instructor exam
what i enjoy like no pose heroes is the
best yeah it's like
you're only on your two hands
and your entire body weight is like
lifted off of your hands
that's you that'll make me collapse
i feel like i'm uh
i feel like i'm at a lululemon right now
what uh where do you go do yoga already
uh core power or black swan
i
do it on my own
oh yeah core power but no i just is it
weird when you're at like a yoga place
and the white person is telling you how
to do yoga it's like [ __ ]
it's like me going to a sushi restaurant
there's a white chef
a little bit but it's a
it's a it's a deep science so i think
there's a lot to learn and
i think everybody can grasp a lot from
it so there's some
something that could be spread from it
you know wow so wise
when it comes to yoga not when it comes
to not dating co-workers
then she's very unphilosophical about
that no i'm glad you're married you know
seems like a great how's your husband
doing what's he up to what's he like
he's lit i love my life yeah oh
let's
well we have no best friend we have no
space for that on this show we're here
to see people
collide into each other horribly
i'm skewing it right now sorry
well give it up for artie and laurel
going on a beautiful date together
full of yoga energy who wants to see two
dudes go on a date with each other
and try to
try to mate
we got two dudes coming up one's name is
tyler brown
tyler brown and gareth
there's gareth coming up
or is that tyler brown
very gentlemanly
they're both
being gentlemanly to each other this is
2022.
oh uh we got a special guest
jamie kilstein going on a date with a
man
world famous comedian from the comedy
store
give it up for jamie kelsey and tyler
brown right
gareth
gareth and jamie kilstein
buddy okay well let's go on a date first
the [ __ ] point of dating guys is that
we could just [ __ ]
and we didn't have to do any of this
[ __ ] and i found the one fruit
mormon guy who doesn't want to just go
for it
all right what do you want to talk about
garrett
i don't know
i like tattoos nice to see a little
monkey there thank you so much yeah i
think this is probably enough we
probably just get straight to it
let's go on the [ __ ] date okay here's
the thing um
what are you the most scared about in a
relationship
let's get vulnerable garrett
that's like super deep uh i don't know
not being enough
that's a big thing so why don't you
think you're enough
well
you know i don't know like you're gonna
make me dive into my fear right now you
didn't want to
if you didn't want to [ __ ] me off the
bat i'm trying to neg you into it while
i'm trying to drop your self-worth a
little bit so that maybe you're into me
you got to ease me into it what's your
biggest fear first not being enough
she's going to both have the same fear
yes and then we're gonna get into a
relationship we're gonna be too scared
to break up with each other even though
it's gonna be go like mediocre for a
while and then we're just gonna [ __ ]
die indifferent so we should skip all
that and go right to the end
and time
give it up for these two gay men
gareth and jamie kilstein you're afraid
to dive into your fears how do you
expect to dive into his [ __ ]
hopefully there's a lot of lube
with a lot of lube
have you ever [ __ ] someone in the
[ __ ] before no not even a woman no
how old are you 24. oh my god i'm so
sorry i asked all those questions
i'm like you have no idea what the [ __ ]
is going on right now
what a night
what's your insecurity i have so much
student debt
jamie kill scene famous comedian
the next one to be cancelled
kevin spacey or gareth over here don't
write to jezebel.com please
so jamie uh have you ever been on a date
with a dude or you're pretty straight no
i mean like uh i'm straight oh no well i
said i sucked the dick in high school oh
i said only one uh only one it was i
don't think i've told this story ever it
was uh my best friend and we were both
uh he had like a super hot girlfriend
and i was sort of the
like nerdy third wheel or whatever and i
was a virgin i was a virgin until uh i
was like you know like 20 you get it and
and [ __ ]
yeah one day we were just like talking
about jerking out he's like well we
could like suck each other's dicks and i
and this is literally what happened i
said i don't think i'm gay and he said
oh it's not gay if you wear a condom and
i go i'm in and then
and is that guy gay now uh he's gotta be
uh i'll i'll check i'll check on
facebook what a crafty crafty gay man it
was a crafty yeah it was the the just a
tip of uh second deck yeah so it wasn't
gay he was wearing a condom yeah so like
i'm like totally straight bro so did you
have
this did he suck your dick or was only
one way we both did okay yeah we both
did beautiful with the with the condom
and that could happen tonight gareth if
you play your cards right
again
sure it's probably better than some
girls
don't be sexist
i i couldn't tell that was sexist
transphobic or just confused and scared
but it was one of them
yeah dude getting your dick sucked by a
girl is the gayest thing ever you gotta
get a
dude
did you suck it to complete
uh yeah yeah i thought i i ain't no
[ __ ]
did you
okay yeah i'm just so interested in so i
i given a bj with a condom on yeah yeah
what's the point of that i mean
yeah it's not i mean i feel like that
was like the least on my like worry
bucket list like at the moment
but like yeah feel good for him
uh yeah so i did that and then
yeah i think that's uh that's the only
gay thing i'm like very affectionate
with my guy friends
um but yeah
no i've just been in [ __ ] terrible
toxic heteronormative relationships
yeah that's the norm that's how you're
supposed to do it that's straight as
[ __ ]
your relationship right now no i broke
up two weeks ago oh sorry that's okay
yeah it was crazy
it was
she that day
said she wanted to get married
then that night
said she's moving too fast and she needs
to break up it's like she got mad at
herself like it was so weird and then
i don't know if you've ever had this
during uh
like a breakup but
it was a fast relationship like it was
just like months like three months but
just like intense intense like we moved
in right away
and
then
like that night
she was like talking to a different
person where like that day was like
we're gonna get married all this stuff
and then suddenly we she called me from
a friend's house and it sounded like it
sounded like she was talking through a
divorce attorney where she's like i wish
you well in your endeavors and i'm like
don't use the word endeavor like it was
very [ __ ] weird and then
i went to
hawaii i left austin i went to hawaii
just to stay on like my friend's [ __ ]
farm i was like oh you're gonna get
bangs after the breakup i'm gonna go to
a [ __ ] farm and i went to the farm
and then i swear to god she
called me and she said she changed her
mind it looks like i'm doing great in
hawaii we should make things work i get
back on the plane
uh and in route from hawaii to austin
she talked to her girlfriends and
changed her mind so i got to the austin
airport with my stupid [ __ ] acoustic
guitar and a backpack like inside lou
and davis and she uh just ended it right
there and like and i was like so i don't
even have a ride from the airport and
she was like no and now i'm [ __ ] on
stage with this [ __ ] chunk of meat
yeah in the cave at 7 30 on a sunday
sure [ __ ] it who needs women we got
dudes we got dudes we got dudes in
sparkly tablecloths then there's a
screenshot of this she probably wants to
[ __ ]
miss me now amy
i'm on a date with a dude you're not gay
stuff because
yeah we're not wearing condoms like a
bunch of queers
gareth have you ever gotten a [ __ ]
before
were you wearing
[ __ ] yeah bro
yeah that's the mouth one right
were you uh giving or receiving
receiving oh no goddamn right and were
you wearing a condom
no i guess it was pretty gay
what's the main thing you're looking for
in a girlfriend
um i don't know good personality of
course nice balls
i don't know being attractive is plus
good personalities plus a lot of what
money is plus a lot of money jesus
christ you're gonna have a hard time
finding a millennial with a gen z with a
lot of money
career driven is a plus
and what is your career of choice i'm in
law school right now oh [ __ ] you're a
blood sucking parasite
to be oh you're not yet you're you're
gonna be are you gonna defend like poor
people or are you gonna defend like the
like frat boys who like you know
are definitely guilty
guys that look like you
are you going to turn on your own kind
is what we're asking
malpractice or tax laws
okay kind of just some nerdy [ __ ] those
are two different things
uh that's cool you know
if you uh if you want to defend a bro
you first have to be a bro
so i wasn't a frat in college so we know
karen
is your dad a doctor no my dad is he
just like does insurance
oh okay
fun i'm not a bunch ladies
don't we call them lunch
people
lunch lunch days
never seen a male lunch lady so i think
we're pretty safe condom lunch ladies
still yeah they probably give blow jobs
with the condom
the hairnet have you has she always been
a lunch lady oh she was staying with mom
and then 2008 she was a dinner mom and
then she turned into a lunch lady that's
really sweet
yeah she's great i don't know
that was the nicest thing you [ __ ]
said on safe you were like i want a
[ __ ] rich [ __ ] and then you were
like i hope i didn't go too far with the
lunch lady nice mom thing
i love that they love that what a
sweetheart out of any of the girls that
were up here tonight who would you want
to date the most if we're taking me off
the table seeing the married one yeah
yeah that was kind of [ __ ] that person
uh
i was just backstage i was just sadly
eating a po boy at the bar and trying to
write dumb jokes and i was like i
creeped around the corner every time
there was like a woman on stage because
i was like maybe i will go on a date and
maybe this is the story after my breakup
or whatever and then i heard the one
person's like oh man my husband's my
best friend i was like go [ __ ] yourself
jesus get off this stage is for monsters
are you just flaunting in front of us
like what what is that who would do that
so weird
any uh any beautiful ladies want to go
on a date right now with jamie kilstein
we gotta have a real heterosexual date
to end this show
okay i'm sorry jamie i tried
suzanne you want to come up bring her
back up
bring her zap
coming on ups thank you gareth give it
up for gareth
he's discovering his homosexual
tendencies tonight
by the way i don't know if she was
actually raising her hand but i couldn't
have an entire room saying no to me
suzanne and jamie kilstein going on a
date for one minute
just wanted to say that god damn it she
wanted to get up here for cat
she's incredible
yeah i can give cat the mic she's very
funny i did compliment her at the bar
so that's how you do this show i started
flirting back there this was a long con
try to be funny i agree i thought she
was very funny she didn't come up here
exactly what he said
yeah oh wait we're supposed to have a
day right now we're not supposed to talk
about that you were very funny when
people come up here and they have like
locked and loaded [ __ ] lines like if
i was back there writing a bunch of gay
[ __ ] for gareth it wouldn't have been
funny i had to connect with gareth and
yeah i thought you were i thought you
were very funny and authentic and i
think it was the that you've been beaten
down by the austin dating scene that i
was like i get that it's fun is it i
mean
you're my man
it's okay
oh i i literally thought you were about
to be like i'm married to my best friend
too and i was like [ __ ] you too
what is wrong are you guys just
torturing single people hey let's get
all of our hot friends and make fun of
the urchins
mr fish is my man though yeah no no i
got it hey buddy this is a scary show
for people to do it's like people are
afraid of publishing twice you killed it
but that now you feel more confident
i mean i have my arm on my table so yeah
yes i'm doing like a [ __ ] lounge
thing um what you said because i
listened you said that the thing the
peter pan stuff you hated yes um is that
is that just everybody having a [ __ ]
podcast
having a podcast
wanting to get a jeep with no doors
what do you want like what do you want
to do that's not peter panny uh
have a boyfriend
i think would be the the the real
[ __ ] man
and time
oh yeah give it up for suzanne and jamie
kelstein she wants a real man
uh what uh so you want to be in a
relationship and have a beautiful
beautiful i would like to be in a
relationship with someone who would like
to
be in a relationship a car with doors
one i would say at some point are they
just like
bloody dudes like are they ghosting are
they just trying to hook up are they not
like non-committal
all of the above that's the word
that's the word
so not to do what i did to [ __ ]
gareth but i have this like hippie
friend
because like i live in austin as like
the law where they're like have you
consulted the crystals and uh she told
me that the reason when i met my ex with
that like crazy breakup i wasn't sure of
like what i wanted to do in my life and
she said that my energy attracted
another person who didn't want who
didn't know what she wanted to do so is
there any way not to [ __ ] put the
blame on you but is there any way that
something in your energy is kind of like
peter panty and you're attracting these
people or is just austin filled with
douchebags
action that my friends just had
is that a yes is she a little to blame
okay look like you're wearing
the problem and you look like you're
wearing the dress you look like you're
you look like wearing the dress that
wendy was wearing in the movie peter pan
dense friend yeah
you look like you're wearing pajamas
from victorian england
not being told we're just all making
discoveries tonight
it's an intervention yeah yeah honestly
you seem very well adjusted and i'm
prepared to blame the men in this
situation
um jamie kilstein doing the long con or
as i like to call it grooming
do not use that word
i'm trying to get you cancelled
um no uh but uh very genuine very nice
guy and i saw you at the bar uh had a
conversation
you are very funny have you ever thought
about being a comedian
no i think you're great you you were
whatever oh god you're panicking
take the compliment
that's how i know she's going to be a
good comic is because whenever someone's
like you're funny i'm like it's just my
dad issues and i hate myself and it's
like thank you
you know i was like but the girl up
there i saw her one time at last and she
was incredible
but
do you think that you would let jamie
suck your dick with a condom on yeah
say yes say yes say no
no condoms
that was the show thank you guys so much
for coming out anything you want to plug
cat
check her out on instagram kat swatner
give it up for cat one more time
thank you guys so much for coming out
drive safe have a good night thank you
[Music]